eu fisheries ministers have reached
agreement on the maximum number of fish
that can be caught for certain species
in the baltic sea
the political accord reached during
talks in luxembourg
means that almost all stocks in the
baltic will be fished at sustainable
levels from next year
i believe this agreement will serve as a
good basis
for the council in december when we will
have to agree on fishing opportunities
in the other eu and non-eu waters
today's compromised is balanced and
based
on the agreement at the regional level
scientific advice and multi-annual
baltic cod management plan
the fishing opportunities in the baltic
sea concern five species
cod herring place salmon and sprat
with more fish stocks managed at
sustainable levels it will be possible
to raise catches for some species in
certain fishing zones
the decision means that the catch limits
data is likely to be made available to
fishermen by the first of january next
year this agreement only involves eu
member states in the baltic sea region